einen schönen abend und wir kommen zu
zdf heute live seit gestern abend ist
klar deutschland spielt im achtelfinale
der em gegen england so weit so gut
das problem könnte allenfalls sein dass
das spiel in der england stattfindet in
london genauer gesagt und das treibt so
manchem die sorgenfalten auf die stirn
der grund dafür heißt delta diese
variante des gruner virus hat in
großbritannien in den letzten wochen
doch stark um sich gegriffen vor allem
die jüngeren menschen die also noch
nicht geimpft waren sind davon betroffen
ist es daher also eine gute idee
fußballspiele mit großen ausländischen
fan lagern derzeit in großbritannien in
england abzuhalten denn diese fans
könnten sich anstecken und könnten dann
auf der rückreise diese variante auch
mit in ihrer heimat in dem fall dann
auch mit nach deutschland bringen
darüber wollen wir sprechen eure meinung
eure fragen wie immer gerne an uns
später in der sendung haben wir den
virologen martin stürmer zu gast
zunächst aber wollen wir nach london
schalten zu unserer korrespondentin
diana zimmermann
hallo und guten abend diana er zunächst
mal zum sportlichen teil deutschland
gegen england das ganze im wembley
stadion das ist natürlich ein ober
klassiker auf den sich die deutschen
spieler wir haben es gestern abend
gehört freuen wie bolle wie wird das
ganze in england aufgenommen wie ist da
die stimmungslage ja auch sehr
begeistert ist natürlich auch für die
engländer ein ober klassiker wenn auch
ein angstgegner wird durch ein
angstgegner
vor allem haben sie ja bekanntermaßen
angst vor den elfmeter fiel nach hinten
mit mit deutschland hier ist die
aufregung groß und die vorbereitungen
laufen wir hatten ja auch schon spiele
hier in london
jetzt allerdings wird die kapazität im
wembley stadion auf 40.000 erhöht von
20.000 beim letzten spiel und das ganze
wird damit begründet dass pensionisten
gesagt hat er betrachtet das als
testspiele weiterhin wo daten gesammelt
werden darüber wie massen ereignisse in
kurve zeiten ablaufen eigentlich war
geplant dass am montag schon freedom day
hätte stattfinden müssen
an dem sämtliche restriktionen in
england hätten fallen sollen tatsächlich
aber hat delta das verhindert die
ausbreitung von data ist so dass die
britische regierung für england vor
allen dingen beschlossen hat dass eben
diese restriktionen momentan noch nicht
fallen können und dass es eigentlich
keine massenveranstaltungen geben darf
aber mit ein bisschen nachhilfe der uefa
ist das jetzt eben trotzdem so ja also
eine interessante und mit sicherheit
auch nicht ganz ohne umstrittene
gemengelagen wir wollen uns mal anhören
was der europäische fußballverband uefa
aber auch was die
weltgesundheitsorganisation wto zu
dieser spielansetzung zu sagen haben
es sind großartige neuigkeiten dass so
viele fans die letzten drei spiele der
euro 2020 in wembley sehen können
die letzten 18 monate haben uns gezeigt
wie wichtig fans auf und neben dem platz
für die essenz des spiels sind
das turnier ist ein strahl der hoffnung
und zeigt den menschen dass eine gewisse
normalität zurückkehrt das ist ein
weiterer schritt dieses wegs ich danke
den premierminister und der regierung
des vereinigten königreichs für ihre
zusammenarbeit so dass wir die endphase
des turniers in wembley zu einem großen
erfolg machen können
das sind veranstaltungen bei denen
menschen zusammenkommen bei denen es
super sprayer szenarios geben kann und
ich bei denen die ausweitung der
besorgniserregenden varianten aber auch
des corona virus generell beschleunigt
werden kann und wir möchten dass in
diesem sommer auf jeden fall vermeiden
denn wir möchten nicht dass die
ansteckungen allmählich ansteigen
und wir möchten besonders verhindern
dass die virusvariante schnell ansteigen
denn sie könnten die gesundheitssysteme
immer noch stark belastet wo die
impfraten noch zu gering
also da hören wir unterschiedliche
einschätzungen diana der eine spricht
also von einem großartigen erfolg und
die andere warnt vor einem super special
event das eintreten könnte was tun die
verantwortlichen vor ort um genau diesen
letzteren fall zu verhindern
ja wenn man den warnern glaubt können
sie gar nicht genug tun das ist ja genau
das problem
es ist immerhin so dass die fans nicht
die erlaubnis haben hier einzureisen das
gilt für leute die akkreditiert sind
über die uefa die würdenträger sozusagen
da wäre
für das finale 500 eva würdenträger
erwartet es werden außerdem 1000 fans
von jeder seite des finales und des
halbfinales glaube ich für die geht das
auch erwartet für die achtelfinale also
für das spiel am dienstag gibt es keine
ausnahmen bisher für die fans es gibt
also nicht tausende von fans die hin-
und herreisen trotzdem ist es natürlich
so dass jede bewegung ein risiko
darstellt das natürlich in den stadien
besonders viele jüngere menschen sind
die noch nicht zwei impfungen haben die
relativ gut gegen data schützen sondern
häufig erst eine und von denen werden
eben einige doch auch bei delta krank
und das bei anderen problem ist
natürlich nicht nur diese 90 minuten im
stadion die immerhin draußen stattfinden
und wo theoretisch max masken pflicht
besteht auch wenn das natürlich mit
zunehmendem fortlaufen des spieles immer
weniger leute beachten wie wir bei den
letzten spielen sehen konnten sondern es
geht um die an- und abreise und vor
allen dingen um das signal das signal
das fußballgucken in großen
menschenmengen völlig okay ist geht doch
und das ist etwas was die experten hier
sehr befürchten wir stellen jetzt schon
fest dass bisher die zahlen von corona
infizierten sich ungefähr gleichmäßig
auf männer und frauen aufteilten und
seit beginn der europameisterschaft ist
es so dass ich dreimal mehr männer
anstecken als frauen
und das wird hier ziemlich logischer
weise wie ich finde
darauf zurückgeführt dass die männer
sich beim fußballgucken näher kommen ja
das ist vielleicht auch noch mal zur
einordnung also der dfb dabei ist auch
die rede von 2000 tickets eben die er
erhalten soll und die er verteilt
hauptsächlich an in england lebende
deutsche also man will da schon die
reisetätigkeit so gut es geht
unterbinden aber trotzdem ist natürlich
nicht auszuschließen dass es da jetzt zu
bewegungen kommt du hast es angesprochen
wie ist denn generell die korona lage in
großbritannien im moment wir haben es
vorhin ja auch im bad hat schon gehört
also delta hat er schon noch mal
ziemlich reingehauen ja data hat
ziemlich reines betrifft inzwischen data
ist inzwischen sozusagen fast jede
ansteckung in großbritannien geht auf
delta zurück wir haben hier momentan die
höchsten infektionsraten in ganz europa
nachdem wir die niedrigsten hatten und
nachdem wir ja auch eine sehr sehr hohe
durch impfungen haben bereits also hier
sind 83 prozent der erwachsenen einfach
geimpft und sogar 60 prozent der
erwachsenen zweifach
das reicht aber nicht um diese dritte
welle tatsächlich zu verhindern das
schwächt sie natürlich ab wir haben
nicht die zahlen die wir im januar
hatten oder im letzten jahr april aber
die zunahme der fälle beträgt in den
letzten wochen jeweils etwa 35 prozent
und da kann man sich ja ausrechnen heute
hatten wir 16 tausend fälle etwa wie das
in den nächsten wochen noch ansteigen
kann
das betrifft wie ich schon sagte vor
allen dingen jüngere leute die noch
nicht geimpft sind zu einem ganz
geringen grad auch ältere die doppelt
geimpft sind etwa 77 prozent aller
infektionen und aller
krankenhausaufenthalte betrifft
tatsächlich leute die zwei impfungen
haben
aber es hilft eben vor allen dingen die
jüngeren und die kinder letzte woche
waren 250.000 kinder in england nicht in
der schule weil sie sich isolieren
mussten also hier gehen die zahlen
wirklich ziemlich hoch und das
beobachtet man mit großer besorgnis
auch weil der nfs also das
gesundheitssystem ohnehin so unglaublich
überlastet ist noch von den anderen
fällen müssen die wahnsinnig viel
aufarbeiten was in dieser zeit nicht
stattgefunden hat wir warten
hunderttausende von leuten auf
operationen und behandlungen also
insgesamt auch eine ziemlich fragile
situation muss man schon sagen wie
verhalten sich dann eigentlich die leute
jetzt so in der öffentlichkeit während
so eines turniers wie der em also gibt's
ja public viewing wie man es ja auch von
früher oder eben auch jetzt teilweise
aus deutschland wieder kind also es gibt
public viewing
hier gibt es das auf to the square das
ist von der uefa organisiert da muss man
sich vorher bewerben und dann werden
verschiedene plätze zugeteilt es geht
theoretisch abstands und kostenpflichtig
war am freitag in glasgow während des
england schottland spiels da war es auch
so dass man sich tische buchen musste
aber am ende des spiels standen alle
dicht gedrängt vor der leinwand und dann
war auch kein halten mehr
zwei unentschieden und die schotten
haben gefeiert als hätten sie gewonnen
das ist natürlich beim fußball so wenn
viel getrunken wird dann funktioniert
eben das mit der disziplin nicht mehr
und das muss man sich natürlich in
dessen muss man sich natürlich auch klar
sein wenn man jetzt diese
veranstaltungen hier abhalten will wir
haben die beiden halbfinale hier wir
haben zwei achtelfinale hier und dann
das finale und boris johnson war eben
gewillt die restriktionen zu minimieren
dafür dass die uefa
träger hier anreisen konnten das sorgt
natürlich in weiten teilen der
bevölkerung noch für einigen ärger denn
hier warten sie gespannt darauf ob sie
in den sommerurlaub fahren können und
das sieht alles momentan nicht so
wahnsinnig gut aus und da finden es doch
die meisten ziemlich ärgerlich dass
ausnahmen produziert werden ja auf das
reisen die andere kommen wir gleich auch
immer zu sprechen fest steht jedenfalls
wenn man auf die deutschen fans gucken
dass eben die reise nach london
jedenfalls schon mal mit einigen hürden
verbunden ist die rückkehr nach
deutschland und auch die unmittelbare
zeit danach dürfte jedenfalls nicht so
besonders angenehm werden wir haben dazu
noch ein paar einzelheiten von rené
severin delta hat großbritannien fest im
griff
die korona variante macht dort
mittlerweile mehr als 95 prozent aller
neuinfektionen aus in deutschland stufte
das robert koch institut gemeinsam mit
dem auswärtigen amt das vereinigte
königreich deshalb als virusvarianten
gebiet ein
das bedeutet unter anderem eine
14-tägige quarantäne pflicht für
rückkehrer auch für vollständig
geimpften genesene oder negativ
getesteten personen
lohnt sich da ein fußballspiel zumal es
auch für die einreise von deutschland
nach england regel gibt unter anderem
tests und quarantäne
diese quarantäne kann frühestens nach
fünf tagen beendet werden mit erneuten
negativen tests wenn das
achtelfinalspiel in london also am
dienstag stattfindet ist fraglich wie
viele deutsche fans tatsächlich vor ort
sein werden
aber nicht nur die fußball-em deckt das
reisefieber in europa sondern auch der
sommerurlaub hat die data variante ihren
ursprung in indien breitet sie sich
jetzt auch in anderen ländern aus unter
anderem in russland portugal und
österreich die eu krankheitsbekämpfung
behörde rechnet mit einer weiteren
ausbreitung
es sei sehr wahrscheinlich dass die data
variante im sommer ausgiebig zirkulieren
wird so die direktorin andrea ammon
bisher stuft das robert koch institut in
europa allerdings nur großbritannien als
virusvarianten gebiet ein
tja also wir sehen für die deutschen
fans die jetzt nach england reisen
wollen da gibts sowieso hohe hürden aber
wie sieht es denn eigentlich aus für die
engländer selbst wir haben gelernt
gerade im beitrag also nach deutschland
wäre schon mal schwierig denn da gilt
großbritannien als virusvarianten gebiet
aber generell dürfen im moment die
briten nach herzenslust ins ausland
reisen wenn man jetzt von deutschland
mal ab city ist da die regelung
die regelung ist dass man auch
deutschland auf keinen fall reisen darf
dann muss man zwei wochen richtig in
quarantäne ohne dass man sich da raus
testen kann
nach österreich zum beispiel darf man
gar nicht einreisen 1 brite momentan es
gibt allerdings länder die tatsächlich
die briten aufnehmen ziemlich zeitgleich
zu dem moment als gut deutschland
beschlossen hat dass sie zwei wochen
quarantäne verhängen haben etwa die
spanier gesagt dass die briten jederzeit
willkommen sind die brauchen einfach
britische touristen für ihre
tourismusindustrie
es gibt also länder aber momentan beruht
das noch nicht auf gegenseitigkeit das
heißt man kann zwar nach spanien reisen
wenn man aus wangen zurückkommt muss man
aber hier wieder in quarantäne gehen
heute haben soll die grüne liste das
sind also die liste der länder aus denen
man zurückkommen kann ohne in quarantäne
zu müssen erweitert werden
das gespräch also das gerücht heute war
den ganzen tag dass es sich dabei um die
balearen handelt und um weiter und zum
beispiel nicht um deutschland obwohl wir
eine so sehr geringe inzidenz in
deutschland haben dabei könnte eine
rolle spielen dass angela merkel ja
gestern gesagt hat sie findet alle
europäischen länder müssten eine zwei
wochen quarantäne gegen großbritannien
verhängen
es folgen die briten eher unlustig
angela merkel heute war heute den
gesamten tag auf der bbc zu sehen mit
diesen satz und man könnte sich
vorstellen dass sie ein bisschen sauer
sind und deswegen auch keine lust haben
deutschland auf die grüne liste zu
setzen
ja also wir sehen da ist einiges an
musik drin auch in diesem thema viel
diskussionsstoff da wird mit sicherheit
auch noch viel und kontrovers darüber
debattiert werden wir freuen uns jetzt
zunächst mal auf das spiel der deutschen
in london und hoffen natürlich darauf
einen positiven sportlichen ausgang
vielen dank für diese eindrücke aus
großbritannien aus london diana
zimmermann dankeschön
ja und wir lassen das thema nochmal
medizinisch noch mal medizinische
einordnen kommen damit zu unserem
nächsten gast und das ist dr martin
stürner büro
ruge aus frankfurt am main und natürlich
auch in corona zeiten ein viel gefragter
gesprächspartner auch schon oft bei uns
in der sendung gewesen einen schönen
guten abend herr dr stürmer es gibt
einige stimmen die ja prominent muss man
sagen sind unter anderem frank ulrich
montgomery präsident des welt ärzte
bundes er sagt er würde ausdrücklich
abraten nach großbritannien zu reisen im
moment um sich dort ein fußball spiel
anzugucken dafür sei die situation
einfach noch viel zu gefährlich wie es
ihre fachliche einschätzung sollten die
deutschen besser zu hause bleiben
ja ich kann mich dem nur anschließen wir
haben ja die bilder gesehen hat zum
beispiel das spiel deutschland gegen
england auswahl und die leute da in
massen über die straßen geströmt sind
eng beieinander
das bleibt natürlich nicht aus und
selbst wenn man im stadion da versucht
alles beste möglich zu machen dann sind
doch solche szenarien einfach
möglichkeiten sehr gute möglichkeiten
dass sich das virus verbreitet und wenn
wir die data variante im überfluss nach
deutschland bekommen wie haben sie schon
zu nämlich ganz unerheblichen prozent
thailand
wenn wir dann noch weitere
ausbruchsgeschehen durch reiserückkehrer
von solchen veranstaltung bekommen
dann könnte es relativ schnell aufbauen
senkt werden ja ich lese gerade mal ein
paar kommentare vor die wir bekommen
haben nancy schreibt unnötig em vor
vollen rängen zu spielen das 0 1 damit
20 bis 30.000 ins stadion dürfen müssen
dann bald wieder 80 millionen in den
lotter und das ist unverantwortlich und
asozial variante doch eh schon hier
schreibt lunare sommersonnenwende und ep
2000 fußballfans sollte möglich sein
aber begrenzte anzahl also da gehen die
meinungen etwas auseinander
der medizinische berater den gibt es
auch der fußball-em daniel koch ein
schweizer der hat die pläne für eine
zulassung von dann ja sogar 60.000 fans
ab dem halbfinale in london verteidigt
er sagt leute im stadion zu haben
bedeutet nicht automatisch ein höheres
risiko
die menschen würden unter
sicherheitsvorkehrungen ins stadion
gehen und unter sicherheitsvorkehrungen
reisen ja alles halb so schlimm oder wie
das klingt das klingt erstmal teuer das
klingt sicher gut es mag vielleicht
sogar im stadion gelingen da diese
sicherheit die man jetzt hier vorgibt
haben zu wollen dass die man die tat
sich sogar einhalten kann
aber es geht ja um das drumherum und das
ist das was mir eigentlich da am meisten
sorgen macht erstens wenn die menschen
da alle im stadion bank gedrängt sitzen
wir haben es gesehen weil den bildern
wenn ein tor fällt oder irgendwas dann
werden die leute aufspringen sie werden
sich umarmen sie werden schreien und
jubeln und eine maske trägt da
irgendwann gar keiner mehr also insofern
halte ich das für so ein bisschen schön
geredet und das drumherum das macht es
so sind noch schwieriger weil da kann
man die menschen eigentlich überhaupt
nicht mehr kontrollieren also die
differenz oder die diskrepanz zwischen
theorie und praxis sehen sie als problem
an kann man vermutlich auch mit guten
gründen so machen die delta variante des
corona virus ist auch bei uns auf dem
vormarsch wird auch in deutschland aller
voraussicht nach die dominierende werden
davon gehen die experten aus auch das
lka einzelheiten zu diesem thema jetzt
noch mal von meiner kollegin meike
verlag bioland die stimmung in
deutschland ist gut
mitten in der fußball-em und
gleichzeitig immer mehr lockerungen
kein wunder denn die sieben tage ins
ident sinkt kontinuierlich
heute liegt sie nur noch bei 6,6 aber
ein neuer bericht des rk ii zu den virus
varianten könnte die euphorie bremsen
daraus geht hervor der anteil der delta
variante in deutschland steigt zunehmend
in den daten ist in der dritten woche in
folge in etwa eine verdoppelung zu sehen
von 4 auf 8 auf 15 prozent in der woche
siebter bis dreizehnter juni hier wird
besonders deutlich wie hoch der anteil
der delta variante im vergleich zu den
anderen varianten ist
während die alpha variante in gelb sinkt
nimmt delta in orange woche für woche zu
das lka warnt die aktuelle verbreitung
der varianten in deutschland zeigt dass
damit zu rechnen ist dass die data
variante sich gegenüber den anderen
varianten insbesondere auch gegenüber
der dominierenden eifer variante
durchsetzen wird
[Musik]
deutschland setzt nun auf eine zügige
impfung
experten rechnen jedoch mit einer
vierten welle im herzen treffen könnte
es dann vor allem kinder und ungeimpfte
ja das klingt jetzt wenig beruhigend der
stürmer
wie gefährlich ist denn diese delta
variante nun genau und was vielleicht
zeichnet diese variante auch aus warum
ist die immer mehr auf dem vormarsch
das erste was die seltene variante
auszeichnet ist dass sie sich noch
besser verbreiten kann noch besser
ausbreiten kann als die alte variante
die sich ja schon sehr schnell hier in
deutschland auch ausgebreitet hat und
die bisherigen varianten nach hinten
gedrängt hat das gleiche passiert jetzt
an verwandte durch die delta dh
ansteckungsgefahr noch einmal deutlich
höher als mit der alpha variante
jegliche nachlässigkeit wird bestraft
und kann zu einer übertragung führen
dass wir jetzt manchmal ein bisschen
entspannter sind und sagen na ja wird ja
schon nicht weil das risiko ist gering
das steigt eben halt in allen szenarien
und deswegen müssen wir jetzt aufpassen
dass wir uns diese variante nicht noch
einfangen inwieweit sie gefährlicher ist
zu mehr schweren verläufen für zu mehr
intensiv richtigen patienten oder gar
todesfällen das bleibt abzuwarten es
gibt erste hinweise dass es in diese
richtung geht und das sollten wir
natürlich vermeiden
wie können wir uns dann am besten vor
den gefahren dieser delta variante
schützen indem wir jetzt nicht zu
euphorisch werden ich kann alles
nachvollziehen ich denke auch im freien
haben wir die möglichkeiten wirklich
viel wieder zuzulassen
das sollten wir auch vorsichtig tun nur
wir sollten ihm solche szenarien wie wir
sie eben auch teilweise bei den
fußballspielen gesehen haben auch bei
den beiden veranstaltungen in
deutschland wenn dann in den biergärten
tore fallen und die menschen sich sich
umarmen das sind alle szenarien die sind
sind nicht klug und wenn man das etwas
geschickter machen dann haben wir es in
der hand dass wir bis zum herbst mit der
delta variante relativ gut umgehen
können dass die zahlen im herbst steigen
werden ist ziemlich sicher weil das
erkältungsviren grundsätzlich tun im
herbst und winter einfach deutlich
präsenter zu sein
es muss keine vierte welle geben wenn
wir bis dahin unsere arbeit gut machen
sprich wir impfen vernünftig durch haben
sehr sehr viele menschen zweifach
geimpft sorgen dafür dass es unseren
kindern und jugendlichen gut geht dass
wir sie mit guten test szenarien und
anderen möglichkeiten vor infektionen
schützen dann brauchen wir nicht
unbedingt eine vierte welle um weitere
lockdown maßnahmen im herbst und winter
es gab noch ein paar stimmen vor nicola
glück über facebook kommt noch mal
zurück auf
das fußballspiel keine zehn pferde
würden mich aktuell in ein volles
fußballstadion bringen schon gar nicht
in england darf ich den leuten die so
was machen meine verdienstausfall
rechnung schicken wenn im spätsommer
wieder alles geschlossen wird ja sie
sagen eine vierte welle muss nicht
unbedingt kommen rechnen sie damit dass
im spätsommer im herbst und doch noch
mal irgendwie größere restriktionen
einschränkungen auf uns zukommen werden
ja es ist schwierig abzuschätzen denn
wenn alles gut läuft wenn es tatsächlich
schaffen mit der impfung gas zu geben
viele menschen zweifach zu impfen und
als gute dinge überlegen wie wir die
kinder schützen können dann muss es
nicht wirklich zu weiteren lockerungen r
lockerung sketche locken
das ist der maßnahmen wieder kommen dass
wir als wieder in einen doktor bewegen
müsst mich ich bin noch optimist dass
wir es schaffen
wir sollten halt aus den fehlern der
vergangenheit lernen die wir mit alpha
gemacht haben wir sollten wirklich nach
großbritannien gucken was da schief
gegangen ist warum es zu diesen
ausbrüchen kommen und da sieht man dass
es eben das zu großzügige lockern das
zuviel zu lassen eben doch einfach auch
gefährlich ist ich will das ganze nicht
nicht schicken böse reden aber es ist
einfach so wir sollten die gute
situation die wir jetzt haben weiter
nutzen können wir sollten uns das gut
gehen lassen und dann haben wir auch
eine chance dass es im herbst auch nicht
ganz so schlimm wird
jetzt stehen nun die sommerferien vor
der tür und egal ob man jetzt zum
fußball reist oder als normaler tourist
irgendwie unterwegs ist dann gibt es
doch bestimmt auch vom fachmann noch mal
ein paar hinweise an die man sich halten
sollte wenn man auf reisen ist können
sie das vielleicht noch mal kurz
zusammenfassen was man als tourist
beachten sollte natürlich auch das
reisen ist natürlich möglich und wir
haben gute chancen weil in vielen
ländern die inzidenz niedrig sind dass
man das auch relativ ungefährlich tun
kann wenn man eben einfach als sich an
das hält was wir hier auch keine
kontakte reduzieren wo es nicht
unbedingt notwendig ist lässt man es
halt sein eine große party oder
irgendeine großes buffet oder sonst
irgendwas aufzusuchen
abstand halten wo es notwendig ist
vielleicht doch auch die maske tragen
dann hat man schon viel gewonnen gerade
in den situationen wo es wirklich eng
wird wo viele menschen zusammenkommen
da sollte man weiterhin sehr vorsichtig
sein vor allem in den innenräumen und
dann kann man auch relativ gefahrlos in
den urlaub fahren also gefahrlos in den
urlaub
das mit der englandreise sollte man sich
besser überlegen im moment das nehme ich
mit aus diesem gespräch
vielen dank herr stürmer für dieses
nette interview und diese informationen
die uns wie immer sehr weiterhelfen
dankeschön und einen schönen abend nach
frankfurt und auch an euch natürlich
noch mal vielen dank für die zuschriften
die fragen und eure meinung das war es
von uns für heute abend
wir wünschen euch einen schönen selbigen
und sagen bis demnächst